did you notice the ashford twins popping
up and welcome to raccoon city what
about the homage to video game voice
acting's most awkward sandwich joke
which of these easter eggs did you catch
in the newest resident evil movie the
zombie infection that overtakes raccoon
city doesn't suddenly transform its
victims into undead monstrosities it
slowly weakens their brains and
deteriorates their bodies until they die
in a reborn shambling flesh-eaters the
original resident evil released in 1996
features a collectible journal called
keeper's diary that details a
character's mental descent into undead
madness they initially complain about
feeling itchy all over before their
speech pattern becomes simple and barely
legible they describe killing and eating
a person calling him tasty the final
journal entry only contains two words
itchy tasty and welcome to raccoon city
claire redfield is visiting her
brother's house when all hell breaks
loose in the quiet mountain town she is
confronted by a woman who writes in
blood the words itchy tasty on the
window of the redfield house
for fans of the game the words bring
back fond memories of one of the most
intimate and disturbing scares from the
original resident evil
in welcome to raccoon city claire
redfield is introduced in the passenger
seat of an 18-wheeled truck having
hitched the ride into raccoon city when
a woman wanders into the street the
truck driver is too slow to notice and
runs her down the sequence is a nearly
shot for shot homage to the scene from
2019's remake of resident evil 2 right
down to the truck driver's fondness for
juicy hamburgers after hitting the woman
the man gets out of his truck to
investigate but the zombified woman gets
up and walks away from the accident
while he's not looking in the movie his
dog licks up some of the woman's blood
unwittingly infecting itself with the
t-virus at which point it bites its
owner in the game however the truck
driver has no dog and is instead bitten
directly by the undead woman the first
zombie ever shown in resident evil
remains one of the most memorable
moments in the history of the survival
horror genre the iconic image of a
flesh-eating zombie taking a bite out of
a stars member before slowly turning its
attention to the player is seared into
the brains of generations of video game
enthusiasts the sequence was recreated
in the 2002 resident evil remake and now
it's been re-recreated for resident evil
welcome to raccoon city agent hunk made
his video game debut in resident evil 2.
he briefly appeared in a cut scene when
he and his men confront william birkin
but he became notorious for his role in
the fourth survivor an unlockable mode
that follows the gas mask wearing
operative as he attempts to escape
raccoon city with limited ammo and
healing items the notoriously difficult
mode featured in both the original and
2019 remake made hunk an instant fan
favorite but he's only made sporadic
appearances since usually in non-canon
modes like the mercenaries and never
without his signature face covering as
umbrella puts a titular town under
lockdown and welcome to raccoon city a
soldier is shown in a costume nearly
identical to the one worn by hunk it's
unlikely he's supposed to be mr death
himself but his gas mask and all black
ensemble are clearly meant to evoke
raccoon city's forced survivor
jill valentine has a wicked sense of
humor and welcome to raccoon city she's
introduced drawing her sidearm seemingly
willing to perform a william tell us
trick shots on a sleepy leon kennedy
that's actually hilarious
later on she demonstrates her twisted
sense of humor yet again when she
ponders the question how would you
rather die being swallowed whole by a
giant snake or eaten by a great white
shark her star's allies are disturbed by
the thoughts and for good reason in the
original resident evil both of these
ghastly phase can befall richard aiken
in jill's scenario richard can be
devoured by yawn a giant monster snake
in chris's scenario he can be torn apart
by a neptune a great white shark
infected with the t-virus
welcome to raccoon city features the
raccoon city orphanage where chris and
claire grew up the orphanage
particularly its outer gates looks
completely identical to the location
seen in the remakes of resident evil 2
and resident evil 3. in those games like
in the movie the orphanage is a front
for umbrella's twisted experiments on
innocent children though the exterior is
the same between game and movie the
location plays a different role in the
games in the resident evil 2 remake the
location is visited by young sherry
birkin who is chased by a more
villainous chief ryan irons meanwhile
welcome to raccoon city has a less
villainous version of irons bringing
leon and claire to the orphanage since
it contains a secret passage to the
spencer mansion
the orphanage isn't the only video game
location recreated for welcome to
raccoon city the original spencer
mansion has certain rooms that are
reproduced with staggering detail
including the stairwell room with all
the paintings on the wall and the piano
room with its connecting secret passage
a character even has to play moonlight
sonata on the piano in order to open up
the secret room on the other side of
town the foyer of the raccoon police
department hq has been fully recreated
the star's office is similarly
reproduced looking just as it did in the
original resident evil 2 and the holding
cells while located in a different part
to the building from the original game
looked just like the original the
protagonists of the resident evil video
games would be dead a thousand times
over if not for their use of first aid
spray this restorative item ironically
manufactured by the umbrella corporation
raises the player's health to full and
has been used in nearly every re game
since the 1996 original it's unclear
exactly how it works but it seems
umbrella despite their heinous track
record of evil misdeeds actually does
make useful products that help save
lives eagle-eyed viewers will notice a
bleeding glimpse of first aid spray and
welcome to raccoon city while a physical
can of the spray doesn't make an
appearance that we noticed the first
scene in the movie set in the raccoon
city orphanage features artwork
depicting the healing item a psa
billboard advertises the product and the
artwork used to represent the can looks
exactly like the artwork from the
classic games
the liquor first appears in resident
evil 2 and has made numerous appearances
since then popping up in resident evil 5
and most of the game set during the
raccoon city outbreak it also appears in
three of the six paul ws anderson
directed resident evil movies 1 2 and 5
for the record and is one of the most
instantly recognizable resident evil
creatures and welcome to raccoon city
only a single specimen is seen but it
leaves a memorable impression first it
stalks leon by crawling across the
ceiling evoking the monster's intro from
resident evil 2. then it sneaks up
behind cheap irons lifting him up and
killing him by eviscerating his face
when his body drops to the ground it
resembles a police officer found in a
hallway in the remake of resident evil 2
whose face is similarly disfigured due
to a liquor attack
released in 2000 resident evil code
veronica follows up on the events of
resident evil 2 with claire redfield
still searching for her lost brother
chris her journey takes her from paris
to rockford island to antarctica
eventually chris and claire do battle
with alfred and alexia ashford psychotic
child prodigy twins who developed the t
veronica virus claire first learns about
the ashford twins when she discovers a
film reel showing them as creepy
children with alfred plucking the wings
off of a dragonfly before throwing the
helpless bug into a pit of ants where it
is devoured this film reel is replicated
almost shot for shot and welcomed to
raccoon city with the twins even
identified specifically as the ashfords
there is an edited in shot of dr birkin
watching the creepy kids implying that
they might be from raccoon and not one
of umbrella's european branches whether
the ashford's appearance is a mere
easter egg or a hook for a prospective
sequel remains to be seen
the original resident evil games are
akin to mazes with locations packed with
locked doors and tricky puzzles to solve
to help players get around pausing the
game would bring up the map screen
showing the player's location which
doors were locked or unlocked and which
rooms had been explored while future
games would focus more on the action and
less on the puzzle solving the map
remain allowing players to easily
retrace their steps and figure out where
to go next as part of his betrayal of
his fellow stars members and welcome to
raccoon city wesker is given a palm
pilot portable device with specific
instructions and a map of the spencer
mansion the map style looks identical to
those found in the early playstation
resident evil titles but in monochrome
black and white
a big part of the classic resident evil
formula is figuring out how to unlock
the numerous doors in any given location
sometimes tasks need to be performed
with key items which usually unlock keys
to open specific doors in resident evil
2 both the original and the remake four
particular keys are coded to the four
suits and a deck of cards diamond spade
club and heart welcome to raccoon city
features the same keys which are used by
claire and leon to open the underground
passage to reach the spencer mansion
from the raccoon city orphanage the prop
keys look identical to their video game
counterparts right down to the colors
the original resident evil was infamous
for its poor voice acting with badly
translated lines delivered by actors who
probably didn't have enough time to
properly prepare or research their
characters there's no shortage of
memeable dialogue that continues to be
shared on internet message boards to
this day perhaps the most famous occurs
after jill is rescued from a room with a
collapsing ceiling after saving jill
from being crushed to death barry burton
remarks
that was too close
you were almost a jill sandwich
the line is retooled in the 2002 remake
too
that was a close one
a second late you would have fit nicely
into a sandwich
the replacement arguably lacks a punchy
humor of the original but at least the
remake features a berry who can say jill
right
welcome to raccoon city puts its own
spin on the classic meme when jill
snatches wesker's sandwich off his plate
before he can take a bite
hey you snooze you lose what still
sandwich now the costumes in the
resident evil video games play a key
role in defining the characters who wear
them especially back in the days of low
polygon 3d models effort had to be made
to keep the characters distinct that's
why wesker has his spiky blonde hair and
sunglasses chris has his sleeves rolled
up jill has her beret and barry has his
red vest as visuals became more advanced
the characters were redesigned to be
more realistic and fashionable several
characters in welcome to raccoon city
dress in a manner that evokes their
classic costumes claire wears clothes
that are nigh identical to her outfit
from the re2 remake and chris is dressed
just like he did in the original game
with his sleeves rolled up to show off
his beefy arms likewise wesker wears an
all-black ensemble and the post-credits
scene gives him his character's
signature sunglasses said post credit
scene also features the debut of ada
wong who wears the same trench coat she
sports in the re2 remake even leon looks
a little more like his classic video
game counterpart once claire instructs
him to don a set of rpd body armor check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]